hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game this one is from
round one of yesterday's
creation ranches uh gran chester it's
vishwanathan anand versus jordan one
forest and
while the game itself is very nice i
would just also like to mention that
i've
visited uh chess club in cisvet a few
weeks ago i think two weeks ago because
anand arrived
he had uh he had to come two weeks
before the tournament starts in croatia
and then he
uh has to stay here in order to you know
be at least two weeks here it's
sort of the regula some coveted
regulations
uh so i had the opportunity to meet
anand and uh i had
uh a book a book you wrote i brought it
so he signed it
and here we have a nice photo there you
have it that's uh anand and
myself uh he he came he
played one blitz game against the
creation reigning champion martin
bosciucci
he defeated him i was a it was a very
nice game i i don't have all the moves
so
i didn't make a video on it but if i uh
uh recover the moves i i will show that
game as well
and he also brought two problems with
him to to challenge the children there
were also
there weren't a lot of people here it
was a very small gathering uh but
uh some of the kids they were that were
present
he challenged them to the two puzzles
and uh
well one they were not able to solve but
the second one they they were
able to solve but they were both
end-game problems so yeah that's
uh there you have it it's always
important to uh to start at the end game
and here
if you guys are wondering this is uh
anand's signature so there you have it
hope you enjoy my stories
and it's a very nice book i still
haven't finished it in its entirety i
came to like uh uh at the half mark of
the book but it really has a lot of
stories
uh regarding pretty much everything
regarding his you know
preparation for the matches difficulties
that he uh had
while uh you know even preparing to
fight for the world championship then
yeah and a lot of very interesting
stories from daily life
so do check it out if you get the
opportunity so that being said
uh let's check out the game anand with
the white pieces opens with
e4 and sorry about that and
congratulations to everyone who
uh scolded me uh so effectively in the
comments in the last video
yes it was a rapid game and i left the c
there on the little robot
uh it's because i wanted to test if you
guys were paying attention
uh that of course is not true i forgot
to update the interface that is the
actual truth uh i
i did update it you know i changed the c
to an r
i just didn't overwrite the interface so
you know it happened sorry about that
uh so e4 and uh van forest replies with
c5 we have the sicilian defense knight
f3 e6 and
now d4 we have captures captures and now
knight to c6 so nothing out of the
ordinary the timeout of variation of the
sicilian
knight to c3 and queen to c7 the bastrop
variation
and now uh while you could continue with
some like bishop to e3 bishop to e2 some
calm variations anand brought the big
guns for this tournament and he strikes
uh
right away with g4 and it's not a new
move it's been a it's been played by uh
carlson has been played by artemiev by
geary by nepo
uh everyone played it pretty much with
with great success
so g4 we have a6 and now bishop to e3
uh we have knight captures on b4 a trade
of knights in the center captures
captures
uh we develop the queen while we capture
and now b5 preparing bishop to b7 to put
the bishop on this long diagonal
queen side castles and now comes bishop
to b7
now we have king to b1 a nice
prophylactic move as
uh rook is coming to see it then you
might have some problems defending the
the the c2 uh pawn and well if this is k
if the king is on c1 and your opponent
captures the pawn on c2 it's checkmate
here at least you can play king day one
so it's a
you know investment in the future so
here knight to f6
and now uh there is one game in the
database a notable one uh from the ftx
crypto car between yani palmish and
fabiano caruana where g5 was played
uh but here anan just plays f3 and it is
now as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game
so let's see how van forest continues
this
uh we have rook to c8 definitely makes
sense
you want to attack the c2 pawn and now
you might have problems if you allow b4
b4 dislodges the knight
queen captures in c2 so first we have g5
now attacking evan forest knight here
and you can't really continue with b4 if
you if you try to go for this then
captures captures y just captures here
there's the double attack on the bishop
and the rook
so black is lost here so instead after
g5 we have knight to h5
and now anand needs to bring the queen
back queen to d2 now if the knight is
attacked it can move and the queen
guards the c2 pawn
so bishop to e7 and now bishop to h3
we have b for now attacking this knight
knights the e to end
d5 now striking in the center we have
bishop to g4
asking black to decide what to do with
this knight and you don't really have a
square for the knight you have to play
g6 so g6
and now bishop to d4 attacking the rook
here basically
uh forcing black the castle or maybe if
black doesn't want to castle you have to
play some like
rook to g8 but it's a it's a weird move
to play your king has to then remain in
the center of the board
so here one for us just castles and now
the position is uh well
most interesting one there are a lot of
very interesting choices here
but there is only one move that's uh
really great for white so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
not at all a easy move to find while i
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations
on spotting this incredible idea yeah
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's not
bishop captures on h5 it's actually e5
so congratulations to everyone who found
it
uh to explain why e5 is so good
uh well uh first let's capture the
knight and see what happens if we
capture the knight
the problem is black has this uh uh
d captures on e4 station two and uh now
well
uh your your bishop is still hanging
here so you have to move it and after
you move it
now we play rook f2d8 attacking the
bishop
and well once we play some like e5 we're
going to attack the bishop and
not even that we can play some like
queen to c 4 pile up on the bishop
it's a very ugly position to be with the
queen on d2 so the queen will have to
move
now you're gonna play e captures on f3
you're gonna attack the knight also your
light square bishop comes alive and
after let's say knight to g3 are going
to play queen to c4 now with a double
attack on the bishop
uh still pressuring the c2 pawn the
queen has to remain there
the bishop here is a monster so uh it
would be
it would be a very unpleasant game to
play for uh for
uh for white so instead after this
castles uh anand plays e5 he keeps the
center closed
uh and now this bishop isn't really all
that of an impressive piece now you are
threatening bishop captures on h5
and it's going to be a race where white
can start pushing the h pawn and bust
open the position or can black maybe do
some damage here with his queen side
pawns so here
knights the g7 of course you're not
going to allow the doubling of the pawns
now
and anand starts his pawn storm h4 with
a5 on forest of course we'll do the same
on the queen side
h5 and now bishop to a6 first
we have knights the g3 the knight will
be a very useful attacker you do not
want to trade it for this bishop that's
pretty much
well it's really doing nothing uh so
here we have
a4 of course preparing b3 and now anand
starts pushing the f pawn so f4
with b3 and now anand could try and keep
the position closed with something like
c3 and then if this is captured just
king to a1 and claim that this is very
solid
but he decides to trade everything so
captures captures and
now captures he grabs a pawn uh and now
uh we have this uh this position here
that one forest really has to take
advantage of by playing
queen to b7 and start going after those
pawns right away
and shift everything over to the b file
but he plays knight to f5 first
and this kind of gives on time to get
back into the game but let's not forget
that this is a rapid game you don't have
all the time in the world to make
decisions
so bishop captures an f5 g captures and
now anand gives back the material now
he's the one that wants to attack he
pushes
g6 and now one forest uh again uh he
could
decide to ignore everything here just
try to switch everything into the attack
but
he captures now we have h captures h
captures and now queen to h2
now threatening just queen to h7
checkmate and if you want to avoid this
you have to start running away with the
king which is what he does king to f7
and now aaron can just continue in a
calm fashion with some like queen to h7
chuck but here ananda
goes all mikhail tal uh on one forest
and he plays
knight captures on f5 and this is just
uh
this is just a beautiful move because uh
well because it's a bad one
but uh for the situation where one
forest is down extremely low on time
it's it's a great move because now you
have to decide
what to capture the night with but uh
you know i'm not just gonna tell you
feel free to pause the video here
and try to figure out the best move for
black while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
realizing that the knight should not be
captured at all
and we should play rook to h8 this movie
is now winning for black
and i had one forest played this it
would be a very tough game for for anand
because now the queen is under attack
and you
basically have to go for this knight to
d6 check and it's not
um nothing good for white we're just
gonna capture it
now we're gonna play e captures on d6
and now comes the the really tricky move
that
was impossible to find the bishop to d3
check
uh that's that's the good stuff uh now
the thing is it
the king can go here if you go here
you're getting checkmated
and you have to capture the bishop but
now what you're actually doing is you're
removing the defender of the rook here
on h1 so after this captures we would
have rook captures on h2
only now white will capture the queen
and now we're gonna capture on h1 with
check king c2 rook captures on c7 with
check and black is not winning
uh but this uh finding this in a rapid
game
uh you know not not happening but uh you
at
your own home you know feeling
comfortable in everything maybe even
having a beer
uh you know uh or or something uh that
definitely could have found this so here
after knight captures on f5 we have e
captures on f5 but now anan's attack is
uh you know going uh
going uh or you know very very
impressively
so queen to h7 check king to e6 now
queen captures and g6 with
check we have bishop to f6 if you don't
block then the king moves and you pick
up the bishop on a6 so you're
winning material either way so bishop to
f6 and now
not just capturing a bishop and allowing
something like queen to c
do check so first bishop the c3
eliminate any counter play black might
have
and even though you're still down a
piece this bishop cannot move you're
going to win it at some point
so queen to g7 now anand just brings
more
firepower to the sixth rank we rook the
h6
now comes queen captures rook captures
and the bishop to e2 now
uh but um you know uh this bishop will
fall at some point
the bishop here will be guarding the
pawn on f6 so we can safely assume that
white will be up at least two pawns
most likely most likely even more in the
future so rook d2 we have bishop to f3
now comes b4 uh we have rooked the c for
now going after the f4 pawn but now
rook to d4 very very nicely done by
anand
we have rook to c7 now king to c1 we
have rooked the g7
uh trying to uh get uh well get out of
this pin but of course
that will not happen just row captures
on f6 we have rook captures and now pawn
captures on f6 and of course you cannot
touch the pawn if you capture the pawn
rook d3 check and you lose the bishop on
f3 and even the rook the king moves you
can even pick up the rook and then
and then the bishop so anything works
here so instead after he captures on f6
we have rook to b7
but this is now very very simple for ana
just bring the king into the game king
d2 we have bishop to e4 now king e3
uh rook to h7 and now b5 we continue
pushing our pass pawn
rook to h3 with check king to d2 now
rook to h2 with
check you can often sense this uh when
uh when a player is about to lose he
starts
just giving checks because that's what
you do you you always have to hope for
that maybe your opponent
puts a king on a really really bad
square and something good happens so
here
king to c1 rook h1 check we have rooked
it rook to d1 now blocking that's how
you get out of check
rook to h2 and now uh well now it comes
the moment that one force was kind of
waiting for but not really of course he
doesn't expect ana to make this mistake
but of course if he pushes the pass pawn
then rook to c2 wins for black
you now have to go under the mask of the
bishop and after king b1 just pick up
this with
check and now it's black who's winning
but of course i'm not about to fall for
that just rook g1 he makes some breeding
room for the king here on d1
we have d for now attacking the bishop
but it's a
uh well it's a it is a move that you can
uh make something out of if the pawn is
not captured if the pawn is not captured
then it could get tricky for white but
of course alan just captures the pawn
rook the c2 check we have king to d1 and
now rook to c4
attacking the bishop here so bishop to
e5 and
now rook to c5 going after this pawn but
now
rook g7 anand says okay if you capture
my pawn here
then it's just check king moves f7 and i
win the game uh something similar also
happened in the game so after rook d7 we
have rook to d5 check
king the e1 now comes with rook to d8 to
check but still rookie seven cher king
d5 and f7
and he was in this position on move 54
that jordan von forest resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
problem is after
well if you do nothing then just rook
here uh
takes away this rook's control of the f8
square then we promote to a queen or if
the rook blocks then we can play some
like bishop to g7 doesn't really matter
rook b8 we promote to a queen and then
you have to capture and then of course
it's completely winning for white you're
up a whole rook
so after f7 uh brilliant victory for
anand in round one uh and uh well we'll
we'll see what happens next uh today's
the second day
uh so we'll see uh hopefully i will be
able to cover
uh many many great games uh but yeah uh
nice nice return to the board by by
former world champion vishwanathan anand
giving you a spectacle like this
uh i would like to thank christopher
denninger 2020 rendezvous cody tutupal
uh kevin keith and robert aratune for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
creation grand chester
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day